je ne te poser une question pourquoi ça
tu après une plongée réparer dette
ce soir du coup des blessures mineures
et ce qui t'a plu chez moi j'ai adoré ta
photo
la tristesse sont envisagées la peine
pour toi
[Musique]
contact est une playlist c'est trop
minoui par mon téléphone
des deux c'est quoi le plan ce soir tu
me dépose après tu rentres chez toi
dormir kotaku d'aller coucher avec moi
vous savez pas mis le clignotant à tout
à l'heure à autant pour moi sortez du
véhicule je peux savoir pourquoi
non vous pouvez pas les mains sur la
tête et mettez-vous à genoux vous êtes
fous toi genou pourquoi vous la réponse
on est dans la voiture je suis d'abord
là
ils se retrouvent dieu a voulu me je
meurs et j'ai fait foiré son plan je
pense pas que c'est ce qu'il voulait
et c'est vous de là il faut qu'on s'en
aille tout de suite
c'est dans tous les journaux
je soutiens votre action c'était la
légitime défense le pouvoir
et ce serait pas nous bonnie and clyde
et noir
comment vous allez semer la police on va
se fondre dans le décor cette plaie je
sais pas encore
vous êtes en sécurité ici
c'est un honneur de vous rencontrer vous
me donner une raison d'espérer
jamais marre de faire profil bas
à la vie à la mort tant que ma
belle-mère garde dans son coeur moi ça
me va
merci pour ce voyage peu importe la fin
[Musique]